so youve got all of these different
sources of information think of for
square where you're checking in it's
telling you where you are at a certain
time and all these different data
sources need an anchor they need
somewhere where it can reside and the
calendar is the natural repository for
all this you have these Network effects
how do you start driving these events
through everybody's calendar making the
whole calendar system and experience a
lot more Dynamic when you have mult mle
data streams coming into one source you
now have the ability to aggregate
information we're pushing out to for
square the the location and then
eventually then the idea is to get also
for square to push in information into
us get the API pull it in put it on the
calendar then it shows up in your
analytics about you know where you were
being able to integrate with with with
tungle or you know other cloud-based
scheduling Services gives you the
ability to just have that automatically
happen and so then you're really zeroing
in on an information relevant and again
being able to forward that to folks on
your social graph whether it's
professional personal or both I think
calendars can serve a starting point for
a lot of advanced functionality social
functionality you can s with your BL
cast feed for instance which we will
show as public events me P makes makes
love what happens to our world when we
can talk to an iPhone and have it
negotiate with everything you're going
to be able
to change your interactions with your
community
with people around you because of C it's
going to
um unlock some potential that isn't
there right now